[موسيقى]
ملكه السماء التي غيرت مفهوم السفر الجوي
وكانت رمز البراعه الامريكيه اقتربت
نهايتها
على الاطلاق اصبحت عباره عن سفينه شحن
جويه واليوم تعلن بوينج اخر طائره من خط
الانتاج بصراحه لقد حان الوقت
[موسيقى]
دعونا نواجه الامر لقد انتهى عصر طائره
الجامبو النفاثه من ناحيه الركاب اصبحت
طائره 74 قديمه الطراز وعفى عليها الزمن
بسبب طائرات اصغر واكثر ذكاء مثل ايرباص
32 ال ار وماكس التي قدمت تحفيزات افضل
بكثير فملوها بالركاب اسهل تخدم في
المطارات الاصغر بسهوله ولا تزال تطير في
مسارات تصل الى 4000 ميلان من نقطه الى
نقطه كما انها توفر لشركات الطيران تكاليف
اقل وضوضاءا اقل وانبعاثات كربونيه اقل
ومرونه اكبر في النشر
[موسيقى]
منذ اول رحله تجاريه لها في عام 1970 جعلت
7 السفر الدولي والشحن الجويه الكبيره
ممكنا لكن حان الوقت للتقاعد على الرغم من
ان طائرات 74 لا تزال تشكل حوالي 20% من
اسطول الشحن العالمي فان حصه الطائرات
التي تنقل الركاب تشكل الثنين في المئه
وتحديدا مع الخطوط الجويه الصينيه والخطوط
الجويه الكوريه فقط
وعلى الرغم من الحنين الى الماضي الا ان
الحقيقه المقلقه التي يجب ان نتحدث عنها
تبقى ان الطائرات الكبيره تتعرض لحوادث
كبيره تورط الطائره
باعظم حوادث الطيران عبر العصور ولكن لا
يمكننا ان نتغا عن سحرها ابدا انما انا
الاوان ان دعها ترتاح بسلام تفساحا
بالمجال امام جيل جديد من الطائرات
العصريه لصباح العربيه للتسليمان واشنطن